if you look at the indictments of the
Russians who were involved in this
influence campaign these very clever
Russian operatives have been
infiltrating social media in the United
States in an effort to set people
against each other and also to elect
Donald Trump but when you look at what
they actually did you will start to see
that is a big exaggeration
[Music]
information warfare against the United
States whatever platform you look at the
amount of material that the Russians
generated was just a tiny tiny fraction
of what was out there according to the
indictment the Russians spent thousands
of dollars on social media ads each
month well that's about a millionth of
the ad revenue that Facebook alone
receives each month it's the same story
if you look at YouTube the Russians were
responsible for producing 43 hours of
political content which may seem like a
lot until you realize that 400 hours of
content are uploaded to YouTube every
minute most of them had low view counts
less than 3% had more than 5,000 views
so clearly this did not amount to much
in the context of advertising online and
the context of online speech information
warfare against the United States
supposedly these Russian trolls were
very sophisticated about the American
political system they knew exactly what
they were doing they knew how to
manipulate American voters but if you
look at what they actually did they look
not so professional a lot of these posts
sound like they are written by people
whose native language is not English and
you would expect sophisticated its
operatives to speak better English so
they could pass themselves off as
Americans they created some very crude
propaganda that they seem to think would
be effective for example as an ad on
Facebook that showed Jesus armwrestling
with Satan now you may say to yourself
that seems ridiculous but but perhaps
people will fall for that
in fact it generated very little
interest very few clicks very few
viewings information warfare against the
United States the indictment makes much
of pro-trump
and anti-clinton rallies that were
instigated by the Russians but it
doesn't tell us how many people actually
participated in these rallies or whether
they came off at all you know there's
one example of a rally in Texas that was
organized to impose Sharia law and
according to New York Times it attracted
a dozen people there was a counter
protest that according near times was
also organized by the Russians and
attracted a much larger crowd that that
could be two dozen or three dozen people
probably now
we know that that some people in the
real world responded to the agitation
for rallies but we don't know whether
this really amounted to a significant
percentage of voters information warfare
against the United States nor do we know
whether any of this advertising even the
ads that got more attention than the one
with Jesus armwrestling Satan whether
they actually changed anybody's mind or
energized them in any way or got them to
behave in any way different from how
they would have behaved otherwise you
know pro-trump people might turn out for
a pro trump rally and see clinton people
might turn out for anthe Clinton rally
but the fact that they show up does not
necessarily change the outcome of the
election or make the United States and
more acrimonious you know Society let
alone so chaos information warfare
against the United States and the reason
that this sort of hysterical response is
rather alarming is that at bottom we're
talking about speech if you look at the
actual content of these ads in these
tweets it's not qualitatively different
from all the you know homegrown all the
homegrown crap you can routinely see
online this is essentially the same I
mean doesn't mean as good doesn't mean
it's substantive doesn't even mean it's
accurate some of the organs might have
held some water some of them were
completely ridiculous that's true of
American political discourse in general
it's simply the fact that these people
were born in another country that
somehow makes this more alarming than it
would otherwise be I mean if there is a
problem with American democracy in the
sense that people are easily swayed by
emotion this is not a problem that the
Russians created this is a problem that
is much broader than that and to try to
blame you know divisions within the
American political culture on the
Russians seems completely absurd to me
it's much easier you know to blame
foreign invaders for these problems but
the truth is that if voters are making
decisions for stupid reasons that is not
the Russians fault
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]